saviez-vous qu'un mégot de cigarette
peut polluer jusqu'à 500 litres d'eau
une réflexion qu'il serait bon de garder
en tête quand on jette son filtre dans
la nature à l'occasion de la Journée
mondiale de l'eau la ville de Tours
organisait ce mercredi une opération
zéro mégot une cinquantaine de bénévoles
ontarpenté elle les trottoir du
centre-ville pour ramasser ses
concentrés de substances toxiques
Faustine Luneau
dispersé dans toute la ville la brigade
verte de Tours et plusieurs bénévoles
tracés mégots c'est le cas de Victoria
en recherche d'emploi qui s'est libérée
pendant deux heures entre deux
candidatures à envoyer je me suis dit
quitte à avoir de la disponibilité et
des horaires plus flexibles autant en
profiter pour faire quelque chose de
bien aujourd'hui c'est pour ça que je me
suis rendu disponible pour l'événement
de Tours Nord à Tours Centre l'objectif
de cette action organisée par la ville
c'est de tenter de ramasser jusqu'à 100
kg de mégots dans les rues peut-être pas
100 kg je pense que ça fait beaucoup
mais si on en fait je dirais la moitié
c'est déjà pas mal c'est la moitié qui
sera plus au sol un seul mégot de
cigarette polluent 500 litres d'eau
quand c'est dans la neige c'est un mètre
cube de neige or c'est mégot sauvages
qui risquent de terminer dans la Loire
avec l'écoulement de l'eau on les
retrouve partout même dans les endroits
les plus invraisemblables les plantes je
pensais pas pour moi déjà j'étais chez
mégot c'est bof Jacques on s'abîme la
santé et autant pas abîmer la planète
mais en plus sans les plantes non là je
pensais pas du tout que c'était ici pour
moi c'était pas une zone où on jeter ses
mégot quoi bilan de cet après-midi 30
kilos ramassés alors qu'un seul mégot ne
pèse qu'un quart de gramme de quoi faire
prendre conscience de l'ampleur de la
pollution tellement mégot genre sur le
sol c'est waouh je suis un peu choqué en
tant que tienne si tu veux je me disais
pas qu'il y avait autant de monde qui
jetaient ses mégots parce que je suis
fumeur donc je vois un peu ce que ça
fait je me rends compte maintenant que
ouais il y en a vraiment partout chaque
année en France on estime que 12% des
mégots de cigarettes consommés sont
jetés au sol soit 7,7 milliards